all right so you haven't watched shows
here what are you currently into then
what are you doing there now i'm into
gundam right now
didn't expect that gundam like gunpla
and stuff yeah gunpla i started making
gunpla stuff i'm doing a gumplum making
stream
and it's really fun it's a rich man's
house uh what's your favorite gundam my
favorite gundam um i um i'm i'm i'm a
fan of a
turn a
ah tiny gundam okay yes
yes i like it i understand
i like the metal orphans one
yes
i don't know anything about gundam i'm
so sorry i like the metal hemoglobin
orphan
i don't know anything about gundam i'm
just again pretending
i think we're all pretending because the
only gundams i've seen unfortunately are
like the mainstream gundams like uh like
wing and like wings
have you been a fan of gundam for a long
time or is it just recently you got into
it recently oh okay how did you get into
it
um
first of all it was gunpla i love making
stuff i
um
yeah yeah
that's why i love sewing i love making
little stuff and it became like um
making
gangnam
i got into it i don't know because i had
time i'm a streamer
to be fair it is like perfect stream of
content it's like a just chatting stream
with something to distract you yeah yeah
i definitely want to yeah cause like i
really wanted to get into it as well but
i know so little about the gunpla world
that i didn't even know yeah you didn't
know about the grades i didn't even know
about the greatness
yeah there's um there's hg yeah uh it's
high grade i think it's it stands for
high grade these are all on the boxes
it's on it i didn't know this why has no
one told me this me neither hd for
beginners yeah so i'm starting from
eight 4k i just recently made um rg
which is um
is it real real
real grade
the only reason i know about gunpla is
mostly through my editor allen who's
also a mecha fan he is obsessed with
big gundam fan as well i've i've built a
few gunpla in my life
huh
yeah actually do you know do you want to
know how i started off uh discovering
gunpla
so my cousin like because here's the
thing gunpla and like gundam and mecca
in general was like super super massive
in southeast asia and i know a lot of
people who actually like they don't even
know gundam but they build gunpla right
because they're just a massive fan of
gunpla as opposed to me right now yeah
yeah exactly right yeah
the gunplaws are more appealing on the
show so i remember i every time i'd go
to my cousin's house um and if you've
been watching trash chase this was the
cousin that uh showed me uh showed me
scary movies when i was a kid right so
you know he's basically my older brother
but i remember every time i'd go to his
house he had this room and he had this
cabinet right that was just basically
just gunpla it was all gunpla
and that's how
i knew what gunpla was right
um so i didn't know you had to build it
so
be me i'm like five six year olds i see
a cabinet full of giant robots what do i
think they're toys
that's not on six your card that's not
honestly okay so the first time
the first time i think the first time i
remember going to that room
um he like he like goes to the toilet or
something whereas my mom calls him i
don't remember but he leaves me alone in
that room for like a good you know 10 15
20 minutes so what do i do um i want to
start playing with the toys
so so i didn't know i thought in
olympics yeah so so this is this is like
i'm describing the paint olympics now so
i see them all on the shelf and i
grabbed two i grabbed two off the shelf
and they start fighting right and then
of course they're giant robots in my
hand what are they gonna do they're
gonna start [ __ ] fighting so i start
going
because i think they're [ __ ]
transformers or something right you know
you know
exactly like the bbc but like yeah of
course so so i started playing around
with them things start flying off think
like a [ __ ] laser sword breaks i
don't [ __ ] know i'm like six year old
and like
when my cousin
comes in he was literally he literally
had a bottle of water in hand he drops
it it was like you know you know that
you know that scene in a movie where
like the person sees something they drop
the coffee he actually just [ __ ] did
that and i didn't know he was in the
room until i heard the water bottle
dropping falls in slow motion
this is the only time i think he's ever
shouted at me in my life
i don't blame him
yeah i mean i i think that's when he's
like started showing me scary movies
because like
he's gonna get me back somehow just like
that scene in community when he walks in
with the pizzas and the whole place is
on fire
yeah i guess i guess gumballs are kind
of like sophisticated legos in some ways
right kind of yeah it's like really
difficult because yeah because it's like
yeah you know you think about it the way
i think about it is that you're the mini
the poo ween
you know the mini the poo meme with the
woman
[ __ ] my brain winnie the pooh meme yeah
the one with a like he's in a suit yeah
legos yeah yeah gunpla
i know i know gunpowden to be pissed off
at legos but come on they're [ __ ]
legos how dare you compare i i had these
things with called like did you have did
you guys ever have these things called
like meccano
did you i had bionicle shout out to
bionicle yeah that was bionicle so there
was like it was like lego and then you
move on to bionicle which is like kind
of difficult
like and then mcconnell introduces like
screws
oh i think i remember this yeah yeah and
like metal parts and then you can build
like tanks and [ __ ] out of it screw the
parts together yeah yeah yeah so it's
like instead of lego that just kind of
like fit together you you get like small
screws and likes and like little hooks
and stuff like that and you like
actually screw it in
and then on top of that is gambler
that's in my head that's like the
difficulty spike i feel so now that i've
like spent my childhood playing meccano
i'm like i'm ready for the next step do
you ever get sean point do you get
stressed out building it when you're
trying to like fit a piece together that
feels like it shouldn't be going
together but the guide is like no no you
put that piece together and you feel
you're going to break something i always
get so nervous around that when i'm
building gunpla it's it's like zen to me
i feel like you need to be there yeah
yeah yeah i get too stressed out yeah
it's very therapeutic
therapy it's like doing a jigsaw puzzle
i feel it's like you gotta be in zen
mode otherwise you're just gonna rage we
did uh we did a race of a gambler yeah
yeah it was still a model kit but uh
yeah that wasn't that wasn't fun that
wasn't yeah um
when you add when you add a relaxing
uh relaxing activity and put a time
limit on it it just suddenly it doesn't
become relaxing anymore what can i say
that's why you rarely see like jigsaw
puzzle speed runs just because it would
be so that sounds fun we should have
that's so stress inducing i mean i'd
love to do it but actually that sounds
like an amazing idea yeah
you saw puzzle speed
i bet there's like there's there's
strats we haven't developed yet because
we're just too afraid everyone's just
like oh yeah just find the corners there
must be a way to like optimize it more
you know speedrunners come on get on it
get on this but yeah come on what are
the strats oh my god jigsaw puzzle
i love jigsaw puzzles oh my god
have you ever met anyone who said i
[ __ ] hate jigsaw puzzles uh
no i'm not hate i've never met anyone
who loves them they're just clearly not
very polarizing i mean it's a
[ __ ] piece of cardboard that you
stick together like
what's what's not to like i guess if you
break it down i mean it's like saying
it's like does anyone have any angry
feelings towards like connect four it's
like no it's like it's connect four no
one feels strongly
about it or against it sure people who
are [ __ ] at connect four yeah probably
how are you [ __ ] at connect four it's
not hard thank you ashley
well tell us the people who keep losing
a connect four what about okay what
about norton crosses what do you call it
in australia what do you call it
tic-tac-toe
they're called naughts and crosses in
the uk
i mean it's like well i'm sure
tic-tac-toe with notes and crosses is
like stress-inducing the people who are
shocked
no it's like when you play that one dude
who clearly just knows the winning strat
and i'll just go for the middle and
we'll just beat you every time
you know then then it's like then then i
can start to see people being like [ __ ]
this
even though it's fundamentally just a
bunch of lines on a piece of paper
rightly it's right
still be stressing juicy
why are we talking about this i can't
remember i don't know where are we going
yeah going back yeah go back to gunpla
so what is your favorite model kit that
you've built so far then
um i filled um
a [ __ ]
yes
it's the one that's kind of like short
and dumpy right yeah yeah yeah why did
you just say yeah yeah
look at it yeah and that was my first rg
so oh
okay it was really hard i i hurt my
fingers
the parts like have to
move around the parts
right you know you know what i mean it's
like without breaking in here yeah
without breaking it it was so hard i was
like that's so stressful god i haven't
had enough time building ikea furniture
you know
it's like that but if the couch is this
big where's the perfect great ikea ikea
furniture that's what i want to know
it's already hard enough
there's no such thing as a high grade
photoshop it starts on like master grade
i get ptsd whenever i thread thread the
uh the screw too much
and then it's like halfway in
the screw you're like oh no oh no i've
got like three turns left before this is
gone and then it starts making that like
horrible squeaking sound
i definitely like building gunpla up to
a point and then like you finish it and
then you're like what's this thing that
i haven't used and it's the [ __ ]
stickers and that's that that's when it
goes from uh that's when it goes from a
uh like a relaxing
activity to just the worst thing i could
ever hope for i wish i liked it
yeah right i wish i was into it because
it would just be something you can do
like on a rainy day right you know yeah
but like i i know there's like my kids
could play with them
[Music]
you can watch their soul leave their
bodies
i think what happens
but i know there's like hardcore gambler
uh
modelers in japan that you know go to
the effort of like you know when you
like snip off the little bits of plastic
yeah and then there's like those little
bits yeah
they're like no no they don't even cut
it they sand it wait yeah yeah